[Music]
I guess the best advice that I could
give to creating really successful teams
is to constitute them with people that
don't think like you don't look like you
don't come from the same place as you
have different educational backgrounds
different cultures the more diversity we
can create in a team the better because
you don't really know where your blind
spots are so that's one of the the most
successful strategies that I've used and
I would recommend to you situationally
appropriate leadership is kind of the
mainstay of the success that I've seen
on all of my Space Shuttle missions it's
not always the the person that has the
title that has the knowledge or the
situational awareness to make the
critical decision many times in a normal
flow of activities you can work by
consensus but there are times when a
leader has to lead and it may not be the
person who's designated the commander it
may be the person has the deepest
systems knowledge it may be the rookie
astronaut who has the knowledge or the
insight or even just an orthogonal view
that everybody else because they have
television from their years of
experience that you know they could not
see we don't know what we don't know and
and so I've often asked after working
with a team for a while
how's it how's it going am I you know
saying too much too little you know is
the is the creative spirit of the team
you know working and I've gotten
actually really good feedback in in the
past and and early on in my career
actually I was told hey no you really
you really need to talk less you and
actually I paraphrase it and I discussed
it in my book you need to shut up more
and that's a hard thing to hear but as
someone who wants to get the best out of
his or her team you really need to to
listen to everybody around the table and
even if you have the right answer
immediately sometimes it's good to sit
back
and let the junior people speak and and
you know really take turns another thing
that we're now spending more time
thinking about is the cross-cultural
issues you know the space program is no
longer a u.s. are a Russian only domain
but it's it's mixing in many cultures
European Japanese have Canadian
astronauts and of course Russian
cosmonauts flying with us and there'll
be other nations flying aboard the
International Space Station in the
future as well so really having a
sensitivity and understanding of those
intercultural kinds of issues is really
important and I've seen this in other
aspects of my life as well I actually
worked as a chief technology officer at
a major Medical Research Institute and I
created these innovation teams that were
comprised of not just physicians and
traditional engineers but nurses and and
respiratory technologists and physical
therapists and even lawyers and business
people people that don't necessarily
think alike but it was really
fascinating to see the people that came
up with these really wonderful ideas
often times it was the nurses who came
up with the best ideas they're on the
front lines of medicine they see the
things that are going well in health
care and the things that aren't they
come up with these jury-rigged
innovations that turn out to be really
really useful in patient care so I
always place great value in creating
multidisciplinary teams and and really
try and focus on empowering
situationally appropriate leadership
you